a caring properly trained physician and
an informed motivated patient that's
your best unit nothing is more efficient
than that anything you pile on top of it
screws with it got it now how do you
know if you have a bad doctor
finger in the ass when you're going in
for a tennis elbow yeah it's a little
bit a little bit of a concern or if
they'd you know we could go a lot of
places with this yeah if they're not
listening to you that's a sign that
something's up right right and it just
all they have to do is listen carefully
the one misconception that people have
is that the doctor needs to spend a lot
of time oftentimes we don't we literally
we know when you walk in the room we
know what's going on right we know we've
seen it a million times we can literally
smell it no